THE DEATH TOLL IS NOW 12,000
PEOPLE.
MAKING THIS DISASTER ONE OF THE
DEADLIEST QUAKES IN DECADES,
CNN'S NICK PATON WALSH IS INSIDE
THE REGION WHERE THE 7.8
MAGNITUDE EPICENTER WAS
RECORDED.
NICK, WHAT ARE YOU SEEING IN
THIS HOUR?
>> Reporter: YEAH, ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT, ABBY, TO SAY THAT WINDOW
OF RESCUING PEOPLE ALIVE IS
CERTAINLY CLOSING.
IT IS STILL BITTERLY COLD HERE.
AND THE COMMOTION YOU CAN SEE
BEHIND ME IS THE CONTINUED BID
IN THE DARK OF NIGHT TO
EXCAVATE.
I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY THEY'RE
MOVING IN A WAY THAT SHOWS A LOT
LESS OF THE CAUTION THAT WHEN WE
SAW WHEN HE FIRST GOT HERE LAST
NIGHT, PIECING THEIR WAY, VERY
CAREFULLY, SOMETIMES, BY HAND,
LISTENING FOR SURVIVORS, IT'S
NOISY, IT'S FAST-PACED.
AND SIGHI ALSO HAVE TO TELL YOU
TODAY, TO THIS TIME, SO CLOSE TO
THE EPICENTER, WE'VE SEEN A LOT
OF BODIES PULLED OUT.
DEVASTATING NUMBERS.
A 4-YEAR-OLD PULLED AWAY IN A
BLANKET HERE.
AN 8-YEAR-OLD GIRL, A NUMBER OF
MEN OFTEN LINED UP IN THE
STREETS IN LARGE NUMBERS WITH
TARP P
TARPAULINS.
AND PRESIDENT RECIP TAYYIP
ERDOGAN OF TURKEY, HE FLEW INTO
THIS TOWN TODAY AS PART OF A
TRIP OF EARTHQUAKE-RAVAGED
AREAS.
I THINK HE ACCEPTED IT TO SAY
THE GOVERNMENT'S RESPONSE THAT
FIRST DAY WASN'T THAT FAST.
AND ALSO FAIR TO SAY HAMPERED BY
APPALLING CONDITIONS.
AND THERE IS ANGER THAT
SOMETHING WAS NOT DONE FAST
ENOUGH.
YOU'D FEEL IT TOO IF YOU FELT
THEY COULDN'T SAVE YOUR LOVED
ONES.
ON TOP OF THAT PIECE OF RUBBLE
TODAY, WE CLIMBED UP TO SEE
MEDICS RUSH IN.
THEY THOUGHT THEY FOUND SOMEBODY
ALIVE.
SADLY, THEY LEFT WITH THEIR
STRETCHERS EMPTY.
AND THE DAUGHTER OF THE MAN WHO
DIED FURIOUS THAT NOTHING HAD
BEEN DONE FAST.
WE'LL SEE THIS PLAY OUT FOR DAYS
ACROSS TURKEY IN THE WRECKAGE OF
HOW ANY PERSON COULD HAVE DONE
MORE, RESPONDED FASTER.
BUT RIGHT NOW, THE DIGGING
CONTINUES, THE BODIES THAT ARE
BROUGHT OUT, SO MANY OF THEM
LIFELESS.
ABBY.
>> SO MANY DOING SO MUCH TO TRY
TO SAVE WHOEVER THEY CAN AT THIS
POINT.
THANK YOU, NICK PATON WALSH FOR
THAT REPORT.
>> EARLIER, TURKISH --
VISITED AN EMERGENCY RELIEF
CENTER AT THE HEART OF THE
DISASTER ZONE.
AFTER GREETING VICTIMS, HE
ACKNOWLEDGED PROBLEMS WITH THE
TURKISH GOVERNMENT'S INITIAL
RESPONSE.
HE SAID THE SITUATION IS UNDER
CONTROL, AND VOWED TO REBUILD
THE QUAKE DAMAGED AREAS WITHIN
A YEAR.
CNN'S JOMANA --
JOINS LIVE FROM SOUTHERN
TURKISH REGION, WHICH IS INSIDE
THE IMPACTS ZONE OF --
THE DEATH TOLL IS CONTINUING TO
RISE.
HOPE IS FADING FOR MANY OF
THOSE SURVIVORS.
HOW, WHAT IS THE SITUATION?
HOW ARE THEY COPING?
>> I'M, CHRISTINA, I DON'T NOW.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE PARTS OF
THE TEN PROVINCES THAT HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY THIS MASSIVE
EARTHQUAKE.
HERE, YOU DON'T SEE THE SORT OF
WIDE SCALE DISRUPTION THAT YOU
SEE IN OTHER PARTS OF THE QUICK
ZONE.
WHAT YOU SEE HERE AS SITES LIKE
THIS, THAT ARE SCATTERED AROUND
THE CITY.
THIS IS WHERE YOU HAVE
BUILDINGS THAT ARE STILL
STANDING IN WITH LITTLE OR NO
DAMAGE.
THEN YOU HAVE BUILDINGS LIKE
THIS IN THE MIDST OF THAT THAT
HAVE BEEN FLATTENED.
YOU HAVE SEARCH AND RESCUE
TEAMS THAT HAVE BEEN WORKING
AROUND THE CLOCK FOR NEARLY 72
HOURS, SINCE THE EARTHQUAKE
STRUCK.
THEY ARE CONTINUING TO SEARCH
FOR SURVIVORS.
HERE, AND THE SITES, THIS WAS A
14 STORY RESIDENTIAL BUILDING.
PEOPLE ARE TELLING US THERE
WERE ABOUT 100 PEOPLE LIVING IN
THIS BUILDING, FAMILIES,
CHILDREN.
SO MANY PEOPLE THAT THERE WERE
FAMILY MEMBERS, FRIENDS THEY,
HAVE ALL GATHERED HERE WAITING
TO SEE, AND FIND OUT WHAT
HAPPENED TO THEM.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN HOLDING ON THE
HOPE THAT MAYBE THEY'LL BE ABLE
TO RESCUE MORE PEOPLE.
THOUSANDS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
HAVE BEEN PULLED FROM UNDER THE
RUBBLE.
ALSO, YOU ARE SEEING THIS WILL
CONTINUE TO RISE.
AS THIS GOES ON LONGER AND
LONGER, OUR PEOPLE ARE STARTING
TO LOSE HOPE, AND WE'RE
SPEAKING TO A YOUNG MAN, IS
SHORT TIME AGO, HE SAID HE'S
HERE WAITING FOR NEWS OF HIS
COUSIN.
A 25-YEAR-OLD WHO WAS IN THE
BUILDING WHEN THE QUAKE HAT.
HE WAS VERY EMOTIONAL,
CHRISTINA.
HE STARTED CRYING AND SAYING,
THE ONLY THING WE CAN DO RIGHT
NOW IS PRIOR.
THIS IS WHAT YOU'RE SEEING
HERE.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE HERE WHO HAVE
CAMPED OUT, TENS THAT HAVE BEEN
SET UP BY THE TURKISH RELIEF
AGENCIES.
YOU HAVE FOOD STATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN SET UP.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
NOWHERE TO GO TO RIGHT NOW.
THEIR HOMES HAVE BEEN DAMAGED,
OR THEY JUST CAN'T GO BACK HOME
BECAUSE IT'S NOT SAFE.
THERE ARE ALL OUT HERE AS WELL
AS JUST FOR WAITING, AND TRYING
TO FIND OUT WHAT HAPPENED, AND
TO THEIR LOVED ONES.
I MEAN SO FAR THEY HAVEN'T
PULLED ANY SURVIVORS OUT OF THE
WRECKAGE OVER THE PAST COUPLE
OF DAYS.
ONLY DEAD BODIES.
TODAY, IN THE PAST FEW, HOURS
BEFORE THAT THEY'VE MANAGED TO
RETRIEVE THREE BODIES.
WE SPOKE TO A MAN EARLIER WHO
WAS IN THIS NEIGHBORHOOD.
HE WAS ONE OF THE FIRST PEOPLE
ON THE SCENE WHEN THE QUAKE
STRUCK.
HE SAYS THAT THEY DID INITIALLY
PULL SOME WIND OUT HE WAS ALIVE,
BUT HE DIED ON THE WAY TO THE
HOSPITAL.
RIGHT NOW, IT'S REALLY ANXIOUS
WAIT.
REALLY NERVE-RACKING FOR SO
MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE JUST AND
THE BITTER COLD.
IN THE PAST HOUR OR SO, IT HAS
REALLY GOTTEN COLD.
WE EXPECT TEMPERATURES TO DROP
TO FREEZING LEVELS ACROSS THE
QUICK ZONE TONIGHT.
YOU'VE GOT PEOPLE OUT HERE,
WAITING FOR ANY NEWS.
HOPING FOR GOOD NEWS.
RIGHT, NOW IT'S NOT LOOKING
VERY GOOD AT THE SITE AT LEAST.
CHRISTINA.
>> HE, AS YOU SAY, WITH EACH
PASSING, OUR HOPE IS BEGINNING
TO FADE.
JOMANA KARADSHEH THERE, LIVE
FOR US.
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR NOW.